このえーと 経典は まずこの名前すごく大事なんですよ
サッレーカという言葉で
まあその意味がすごく大事です
サッレーカっていうのは
この 適当な日本語はあります
あると思いますけど このなんか
まあしつこいみたいな意味なんですね
でもそれはあまり良くないんですけど
あの まあ何と言いますか
一般的に見えますけど
あの 私はあまり適当な日本語の単語が思い浮かばないんです
例えば もう人はもういちいちいちいち人にいろんなこと言って
もうあまりにもきみ細かくて
人にこうしなさい ああしなさいと
まあもうしつこく言うことなんですね
余計にことまで言うと
だいたいこの母親は子供を育てる
しつけをする時でも まあそういうふうな
そこまで言わなくてもいいんじゃないかというぐらいの言い方なんですね
だからしつこいというか
何と言いますか 何かすごくぴったしはめる日本語の単語はあるんです
まあ思い浮かぶのはなんかしつこいというぐらいの言葉ですけどね
懇切丁寧  似ている単語ないんですかね
なんかこう まあしつこいという
まあ口うるさいっていうことでもないんです
まあそういう  口を酸っぱくして
口やかましい  もう   やかましいもしつこいもいくらか似ています
そういうふうな意味なんです
諫めるですか  うん？ 諫める
まあしつこいということで
ほんのちょっとのことでも
もう許さないというか
もう厳しくやかましく
まあ言う  口うるさい  くどいな
くどいという そういうくどいという意味なんです
で そういうふうな意味があるんです
そこでそれはもう批判的な意味で
で その言葉をお釈迦様は逆に使うんです
良い意味で取っちゃうんです
ということは 微妙にきみ細かく何かをするという意味で
まあ荒っぽい仕事ではなくて
もう精密に何かをする場合は
まあ微妙にでも間違いは失敗はしないで
もう完璧に精密に何かやる
やりこなすという意味で
もうお釈迦様がこの言葉を使っているんです
普通の意味はもうくどいという意味なんです
で それは一般的な意味で
それもまあくどいわけでもなく
もう口うるさいわけでもなくて
これは物事をやる場合は
もう完璧に精密に もう微妙な微かな間違いでもないようにするのはかっこいいんじゃないかと
すごく繊細でという だから
そういういい意味でこの経典で使っているんです
えーと だからこの この経典の意味からも大変この大事な経典なんですけど
まあ仏教徒にとっては
まあ特に出家にとってはすごく大事な経典で
あの  何かやるんだったらすごく完璧に
あの すごくしっかりとやらなくちゃいけないという
そこで日本訳では戒めという言葉にしたんです
ですから で 仏教は自分を戒めることだから
もうそういう単純な意味ではないんです
この文字通りのもう戒めなんです
だったらもうきちんとしっかりと
この優柔不断ではなく
あの もうもう まあ気になったらやるとかね
そういうだらしない性格ではなくて
ものすごいもうしつこくしっかりしなさいという
やるならばしっかりやれという
というこの性格的なところなんですね
だから テキストを通して書き本
日本訳する場合はね くどいとかね
そんなのはもう（笑）書きませんだからね
そこであの お釈迦様がこの祇園精舎に住んでいた時の話で
この八十大阿羅漢の中で
このマハーチュンダという大阿羅漢がいたんです
で マハーチュンダ長老と何か会話がありまして
その会話からまあ出てきたお釈迦様の考え方なんですね
で マハーチュンダ長老が何か仰いますかというと 「
ヤーウィマーバンテー
アネーカ・ヴィヒター ディッティヨー ローケー ウッパージャンティ アッタワーダパティサンユッタッチァ ロークワーダパティサンユッタワー
」
ఆదిमेव नुコバンテ ビククノ マヌシカロト エワン エテーサン ディッティーナン パハナン ホー
ティ エワン エテーサン ディッティーナン パティニッサッコ ホーティーティっていう
ところで このマハー・チュンダ・チョロが
この世の中にある あの
あらゆるこの考え方あります
その考え方は まあ二種類に分けてるんですね
一つは自分に対する 自分って何者かという考え方
と言ってもわからないでしょう
で 大体世の中で哲学などなどの本なんか
あのもし読んだことがあるならば
こう二つに分けられます
一つは自分というものの研究なんですね
自分で何者かという研究
もう一つは ローカワーダというのは
まあ世界って何なのかというね
で そういう二種類に分けられるんですよ
仏教の分け方だから単純というふうに思うかもしれませんですけど
まあもしかするとその二つに入ると思います
で 私ってなん-何というふうに研究して
もう考えて考えて 私に対するいろんな意見を
まあ作ったりする で 私はなんで生まれたんですかと
私って何ですかと 生まれて死んでからどこに行くんでしょうかと
行くところはあるんでしょうかと
で そういうふうないろんなことを
まあ私に対するいろんなことを考えたりする哲学はあります
もう一つは まあ世間に対する考え方なんですね
自分のことは全く考えないで
まあ世間ってどういうものかというふうに考える
それで考えた結果として
いろんな哲学的な 宗教的な
あの意見が出てくるんですね
もし あの聖書のようなテキストをね
まあ読んでみると で こういう本なんかはね
まあ読んだ方がいいと思いますけどね
で あまり恐れ多くて もうよ-読んではいけないとか思ってる場合もありますけどね
で やっぱり聖書なんか読んでみると
まあ世間という立場から考えてるんですね
で 世界の哲学なんです
で 世界はどう現れたかと
それで世界の中に人間いるんだから
例えば人間がどう現れたかと
まあそこから自分というところに来るんですね
しかし あの自分の勉強は聖書にはないんです
私の勉強っていうのは全くもない
まあ世界というところから来て
まあ世界の中の一部として
まあ扱ってるだけなんですね
ですから 聖書とコーランの哲学っていうのは
もう世界に対する哲学なんですね
で そこである一箇所に全部まとめるんですね
神という一箇所にまとめて
ここから世界が現れて-- 現れましたと
それで世界の中に人間がいるんですね
だから人間が世界の一部なんですね
そこで人間に価値あるか
私に価値あるかないかっていうことは
このスタートした初めの
あの神という まあ存在とのどの-- どれくらい関わりがあるか
どれぐらい離れてるかっていうことによります
だから最初は まあまず世界があって
そこから人は考えるんですね
で ああ 世界があるんだそうと
なんでこんなことあるんですかと
といったところで先へ行って
これがある一箇所から全部発生したんだと
で 決める この一箇所は神と呼ぶんですね
神っていうところから世界が現れてきたんだと
それで世界の中に自分もいるんですね
自分と世界との関わりは
自分の存在価値っていうのは
神とどれぐらい近いかという
神が無茶苦茶作ったものだから
もうゴミも作るでしょうし
だから関係ないものも作る可能性もあるし
そうすると 神にとってはこれはもうゴミだ
処分するんだっていう風になっちゃうと
神と自分との関係が全くもう違ってしまうんですね
だからその教えではそういうふうな考え方で
だから神が自分で作った世界も
またもう必要なものと
もういらない邪魔なものって二つと出てきたんです
だから邪魔なものは神が処分しちゃうんですね
だから処分される側に自分がいるならば
もう自分と神の関係っていうのは
この世界と宇宙と関係っていうのはもうほとんどなくなっちゃうんですね
もう処分されてもう無にしてしまうんだからね
で 神という立場から見れば
これは必要なものよと思っちゃうと
存在価値が成り立つんですね
それでキリスト教っていうのは
この自分にどうすれば存在価値が現れるかっていう説明なんです
哲学的に見ると キリスト教はそういうことなんです
だから ある個人が自分に生きる価値があるかないかと考える
自分に生きる価値が成り立つのは
神に近ければ近いほどだと
遠ければ遠いほど存在価値が薄れていって
遠くなってしまえば その関係が切れてしまったら
もうゴミとして処分されちゃうんですね
ゴミとして処分されても
元は 1箇所から発生したものなんですね
だからゴミとして処分されるものっていうものにも
やっぱり大本があった方がいいんですよ
だから大本がなければものは現れないという態度で
そうすると世界の大本は神であって
それでゴミになるものの大本はサタンであるっていう風にするんですね
そこで処分するときは
サタンと一緒に そういうものは全部
そのカテゴリーに入るものは全部処分してしまうんですね
それはいつかということは人間はわからないし
それ神しか知らないということで
だからこの そこら辺はわかると思いますけどね
日本では仏教よりはキリスト教っていうのは随分なじみがあるんだから
その思考はわかると思いますけど
それでキリスト教のその高度な哲学はどういう
あのグループに入るかというと
世間論というところに入るんですね
イスラム教もそういうことで
そこでこの動植物の中で
人間に価値を入れるために
あえて神が人間に魂を吹き込んだと
言って 他のものには魂を吹き込んでないんですね
それで神が自分の大事な何かを人間に入れているんです
そこで人間に生きる価値があるんです
そうすると まあ随分冗談な教えになりますけど
人間には生きる価値があるんだっていうことを考えてみると
それでさらにゴミ論が発生して
この神が この魂が汚れて
いるとかね そこで個人個人でこの汚れを落とさなくちゃいけないと
それはもう人間にはできないと
なぜならば人間知る以前にまた元に行っちゃうんですよ
何でも最初の時点に考え方を持っていくんですよ
そこで人間作られたその最初の時点でも汚れてたんですね
だからもう我々の手に負えるものじゃないんです
そこでこの汚れを落とすって言えば
やっぱり大元から何かこの作業場というかね
この工場でこの欠陥を直してくれないと
ここら辺ではできないんだと
というわかりやすい話なんです
清掃元でそれを直さなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで宗教として運営できるような態度をそれから作るんですね
で みんなに魂あるんだから生きる価値があるんだよと言った時点で
宗教として商売できないんです
排他思考がないと宗教にならないんですね
差別思考がないと だから一部を捨てて一部を認めるという考え方がないと宗教にはならないんですね
それでこの魂を綺麗にする人々とそうしない人々と分けて分けてしまう
で ユダヤ教になってくると
ユダヤ人は神の特別な存在で選ばれた民のためで
彼らには生きる価値がある
で 他の人には生きる価値がないんで
選ばれたものではありませんから
で それで一つの宗教が成り立つんですね
厳密なこの排他思考がそこでありますから
この正真正銘の宗教なんですね
でも ユダヤ人の場合は
この考え方 あまりにも狭すぎて
ユダヤ人だけ救われるんだから
他の人々は救われないんですね
それでそちらに現れたもっと欲が深いこのポールやらね
で そういう人々はもっと広げよと
この教えをということで
あのイエススのいろいろ言った話やらね
そういうのをあっちこっちで適当に揃って適当に解釈して
他の人々にも救われないわけじゃないんだということで
ユダヤ人以外にも広げたんですね
で 歴史的な傾向で言えば
ユダヤ人はキリストを捨てちゃったんですね
なかなかまともなことを言ってるんではないかといって
ユダヤ民族以外の人々は耳を傾けたんですね
なかなかいいことを言ってるんではないかって
そこでこのユダヤの そのこの伝道師たちがそちらで元気で商売やっていたんです
それでユダヤ人以外にも
やっぱり人は救われるんだという考え方が出てきて
その場合はもうイエス様が殺されたことによって償いですね
それによって人の罪がなくなるんだと
ですから それは認めるだけで
我々の罪が全部消えてしまうと
イエスは確かに受難しましたと
我々の現在の罪のためにと
それを信じるだけです
信じれば もうこれで心魂が綺麗
そういう人々はもう救われる
そのイエスを認めない人々は救われないという風に
また 2つに分けて それで正真正銘の宗教というふうな成り立つんですね
それもちょっと狭すぎということと
もっとド派手に言わなくちゃいけないということで
イスラム教が出てきたんです
同じテキストなのにみんな使ってるのは
そこでジーザスなんかいらんと
直接自分が神に言えばいいんだと
誰も媒介する必要はないんだと
で 神が作ったんだから
直接神に言えば全部罪を消してくれると
ということで キリスト教よりも排他主義なんですけど
この幅がもっと広くしたんですね
イスラム教は これ以上広くすることはできないということで
イスラム教は自分たちが最後の教えだと
これからは宗教は現れませんと
モハメドというあのあの聖人が最後の預言者であると
それから預言者現れたら頑固と反対して潰しちゃうんです
現れるはずがないと っていうところで
全ての他の宗教は潰すっていうことになっちゃうんです
人間は直接神に訴えればいいと
だから聖職者は要りませんと
だからイスラム教では聖職者はいません
みんな普通の世間の人々なんです
そんなもんで そういう思想っていうのは
この世界はどういうものかと考えた上の結果なんですね
そこまでは皆様がお分かりになると思いますけど
インド文化では自分は何者かっていうところも考えた人々もいるんですね
それはだいたい諸宗派なんですけど
世界から始まるんじゃなくて
自分から思考を発生するんです
現代ヨーロッパの哲学の中でも
この自分との存在を考える哲学は広げてしまったんです
で もう飽きちゃったんですね
世界論では で まだ科学とかいろいろ発展するでしょうし
科学も世界を研究するんだから
まあそこら辺でしっかりした結論出ますから
まあ飽きちゃったんですよ
もう 例えば宇宙はどういうものかとか
科学者はそれなりに計算して考えて
いろんな妄想しては喋る
科学者の妄想っていうのは
世界ではすごく事実として認める
で それなりに論理的なところもあるし
データも出したりするし
例えば地球は平らと思ってたのに
科学者によってみるとこれ丸いんですね
だから宗教が語る世界論はよしましょうと
その代わりに個人に語れるのは自分のことなんですね
だから自分で何なのかというふうなことで哲学を発展していったんですね
だから 現代で現れた西洋哲学っていうのは
ほとんど自分という立場なんですね
それでエンピリシズムというものがありまして
えーと プラグマティズムというね
哲学思考がありますし
またこの実存主義ですか
で これもあるし まあいろいろありますね
実存主義はフランスやイギリス系で発展してあって
プラグマティズムというのは何論ですかね
日本語で   合理主義とか言います
合理主義 あ 合理主義ですね
そういうのはアメリカ中心の哲学者が作ったりして
どちらにしたっても 私はどうすればいいかと
私は何者かという思考なんです
それから こう何も信じられないとか
ロジカルポジティヴサムという考え方があって
これ大体まあそこら辺でですか
この発展はあまりヨーロッパでは見えません
そこからは で どこから見たってもこれ繋げがあるんですよ
私のことを考えて そこから世界の存在を説明するか
世界のところから考えて私のことを説明するか
だから キリスト教にしたっても
神のところからごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ言って
最後に自分がどうするべきかというところに来るんですよ
神に似るという 賛嘆しなさいというところで来るんですね
で 私は何者かと考え出しちゃって
ずっと行って 神は何者かというところにまた行くんですね
だから 世間に関わる思考であろうか
自分に関わる思考であろうか
そこはまあ スタート時点が違うんですけど
お互いに向かって歩むんです
だから 世間を考えた人は私で止まっちゃうんですね
私のことを考える人は
世間の始まりで そこで思考が止まるんですね
そこで我々知っている哲学っていうのは
その交差するところの哲学なんです
神だけの話はないんです
聖書には 神と自分との関わりの話なんです
いわゆる うん だから神から考えて考えて考えて
そうすると私はどうするべきかということに来るんですよ
そこで私はこのようにするべきかというところに厳密に止まっちゃえば
私論になっちゃいますけどね
そこじゃなくて この 最終点に行く前に
どこかで交差点があって
そこら辺でテキスト出来上がって哲学になっちゃうんですね
で 私はどう生きるべきかというね
私の存在に対する考える人々も
個人のことで終わらなくて
どんどんそれを広げていって世界論にしようとする
しかし 世界のすべてのギリギリまで行かないで
で この途中で交差するところで作っちゃうんだ
作るんです 哲学 だからすべての哲学っていうのは
そうやって私と世界という間で
まあ向こう向かってきて
そこで交差するところはまあまあいいんじゃないかっていう
で このブーバーとかなんとかとか
ドイツ人の哲学者とかね
で 私はというところで始めて
そこで神を存在 存在 神の存在がだからあると
私がいるんだから神がいるのは当たり前というふうに言うんですね
だからすごく あの 日本では人気ある哲学なんですね
それで あれでもなんかすごい単純に神の存在はわかるんだけど
私なかなかわからないんですけどね
頭が悪いなと思いますけどね
私はブーバーっていうのはもうただのバカで見えるんですね
で あれほどアホがなんで世界的な人気ある哲学者かとわからないんですけど
そういうことで このまあ一応仏教はそんなに難しいことを考えませんから
ただまあ世の中の哲学
宗教 思考っていうのは種類だよと
一つは世間に対する思考
もう一つは私に対する思考
で 私中心に考える哲学っていうのはなかなか少数派だから
あの あまり皆様が知っている例っていうのは出せないんです
あることは確かにあります
で もしかすると聞いたことあると思いますけど
老子という人がいてね
まあ中国かな で だからその人の思考も私から始まるか
世界から始まるかということはなんかわからないんですよ
で あの道というか道というね
何か道というね 概念をとって
そこを求めて道があるんだと
道って何なのかと だから彼がいきなり道という単語から始まるんです
で なぜならば その単語自体はすごくこの複雑で
道の意味は何なのかと
やっぱり道っていうのはもう歩むところだから
そこは私にも世界にも当てはめる
見るんですね 当てはめてみるんですよ
だから私は歩むべきところ道であって
世界が歩むべきところもまた道であって
それで個人個人で勝手に思って歩む道っていうのは
もう道にはならないんですね
だから道に道と言った途端
道は道でなくなりますよとか
あれが堂々と言うんです
で それだったら何か道がないんですかと探すんですよ
私の道はこれですと言ったら
それは道じゃありません
自分勝手なことだからね
それは それだったら その道は何なのかというと
なかなかもう人間にわかる言葉では喋れませんね
ただ 言葉でガチャガチャガチャガチャと遊ばなくちゃいけなくなるんですね
とにかく彼が考え出す道っていうのは
私も歩むべきものであって
他人も歩むべきものであって
世界のあるべき姿であると
それでは世界って何なのか
どこから始めたんですか？っていうとこまで行かないで
途中である交差点のところで老師の思考はストップしているんです
だから どんな哲学学者の思考もこの交差点で止まるんですよ
私から始めて神まで行かなくちゃいけないんです
神から考え方始まる人は
私のところまで来なくちゃいけないんですよ
その道で真ん中とかどこら辺で交差点があるんですよ
その見つかるところ そこがもう哲学者の世界なんですね
だから何でもごちゃごちゃ言う
世界論も語る 個人の生き方についても語る
交差点だからね そちらの喫茶店にみんな集めているんだから
いろんな話をするところなんです
その休憩所で だから普通の人には聖書を読んで
これは私の生き方を説明しているテキストか
神の状況を説明しているテキストかということはわからないんです
どんな哲学の本を読んでみたって
これは世界の生命のことを説明しているか
あるいは私個人のことを教えているかということはわからないんです
交差点ですからね しかし
もっと明確に見ると その人はどこから始めてどこへ歩んでいるかということ見えるはずなんです
スタート地点はどこですか？と
いわゆるブーボの場合ははっきりと私はというところから始まるんです
で 私とあなた 私と彼という考え
言語から始まるんですね
彼が言うのは 私と彼という場合は
関係はすごく単純で明確ですと
私とあなたと言えば関係は完璧だと
そこで自分の存在と他の存在の関わりを考えているんです
ですから 私と もう死ですね
彼というね 場合は完全な関係ではないと
そこと死と ドゥといえばもう完璧なもうパーフェクトな人間関係できているんだと言いながら
だからドゥが存在すると
だから神がいるのは当たり前だと
だって言葉であるでしょ
あなたという言葉っていうぐらいの話なんですよ
そこも明確にこの交差点の思考なんです
そこでそれは今私はそういうことを説明しましたけど
まあブッダにはそんなのは興味はないんですね
お釈迦様の立場 仏教の立場というのは
そんなのはうるさいんだから捨てましょうという
そんな考え方 だからそういうものにはディッティといて言って
人の意見ですと 言ってもすごい違うところから考えちゃいますから
これまた人間は理解しようとはしないんです
それで全てディッティですと
意見だから 人間の頭でどんな意見でも現れるでしょうに
ということで まあどうったことはないと
そこでこのマハチュンド長老いうのは
みんな自分の意見が正しいか間違っているかっていうことに困っている
で 神 大元は神であると言った人々は
一番困っているポイントは
そういう神本当にいるかということなんです
だから我々よりも神の存在に対してすごく苦労してるんですよ
神を信じてる人々は いるんだっていうことを設定したところで
本当にいるのかっていうことは
それからもう証明しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからその証明の話なんですね
このエジプトから奴隷になっていたユダヤ人たちが
人殺しながらイスラエル目指して行った旅は
だから一つも神の存在は見えなかったんです
その旅の中で 約束の地はもらわなかったんです
この最近この 五十年前までは
これ紀元前二千年か千五百年の前のエピソードですけど
そこから苦労しながら苦労しながら
もうずっと砂漠をさまよいながら歩いたんですよ
だから一つもいい経験はなかったんです
ずっと殺し合い 殺し合い
殺し合い で 結局は約束の地っていうのはないんですね
行ってみたらそこでまた奴隷というか
で それでも頑固ともう信じていて
探しちゃうという だから神の存在に対して書いている本というのは
あれほどたくさんあること自体は
そのすごく疑問を持ってるんだっていうことなんです
だから安らぎはないんですよ
神はいるんだったらいるそれで終わっちゃうでしょうに
話は 神の存在について膨大な哲学を書く必要ないでしょうに
なんで書くんですか？やっぱり言ったことは本当かないかと言わないと
この責任なんですよ だから余計な思考を作っただけで
ものすごく困ることになったんです
それで証拠ないなくても頑固と信じればいいというふうなこの考え方になってしまって
神は自分の側にいるんだから
自分が神の側にいるんだから
もうこれは勝利得るのは当たり前だと
そこで人殺して勝利を得たら
自分の側 神がいるっていうことは証拠ではないかというふうに考え方になるんです
それで人殺しに行くんです
で 人殺しに行っても証拠ないんですよ
なぜかというと ある国の人々を殺す
自分が勝ちますけど まだ間もないうちに他の国から来て
こいつの連中潰れちゃう
潰しちゃうんですね で
まだもう証拠足らなくなっちゃうんですよ
アフガンにいたあの 何人でしたっけ？あのまあ
いいますか  いえいえ あの
あの タリバン タリバンというのは
あの まあ神学校というみたいものだそうですけどね
で それの学校で勉強して
やっぱり絶対的な存在神だから
それはもう徹底的に神言う通りにすると神一番近いんだから
もう成功するのは当たり前
だから同じ神を信じる人であろうとも
このちょっとちょっと生ぬるくなる人々は潰した方が神は喜ぶんではないかといって
自分たちは必ずしも勝つという態度でいたんですけど
負けてしまったんですね
そうするとまた頑張らなくちゃいけないんですよ
いいすか で テキスト教もそうでしょうし
自分たちが神を信仰しているんだから
世界でどこへ行ってももう見事に勝てるはずだと思って踏ん張っちゃったんですけど
結局人はたくさん殺したんでことは確かに殺したんですけど
結果として神を信じる人々はほとんど少なくなっちゃったんですね
だから真面目に神様を信じる人々っていうのは
こう アジアとかね そこら辺にいるかもしれませんけど
ヨーロッパにはいないんです
アメリカでもいないんですね
まあ知識人だったらもう誰も信じない
ところかもうローマ法王さえも信じてないんだからね
よくよく言ってることやら書いてるものやらね
そこを見ると この疑がキャバレスに働いてるんです
明確な証拠は誰にもない
だからいろいろ推測 推測
推測で何か自分で説明できんこと 「
あ ほら 見てください 神ではないか」とすぐ言ってしまうんですね
だから そういう人々がこの神っていう概念が作ったことによって結構苦労している
心の安らぎがなくなっている
この心の安らぎを作ると思ってはいるんですけどね
だからこの どこを考えたっても人が困るだけ
例えば私は何者か 何者か
何者かと 考えれば考えるほどどうなるかというと
あまりにも困ってしまうんです
どんな概念を入れても
次にはもう限りのない困るというかね
ものは出てくる 例えば私には永遠の魂があるんだと
それは神が作っても作らなくてもいいんです
例えばインドのジャイナ教とかね
バラモン教以外の宗教では神がいないんですよ
しかし 魂があるんです
みんなに一個一個あると
大元の魂は認めません
大元の魂があって そこから一部一部分けて
人間の個人の魂があるというふうに思うのは
それはヒンドゥー教なんです
しかし ヒンドゥー教の中ですごい諸宗派通して仏教も一つでしょうし
ジャイナ教も一つでしょうし
それも潰されちゃったんですね
[背景音楽]で ジャイナ教はほんのいくらかあるんですけど
仏教は全くもない インドでは
で それで個人には一個の魂があるんだと思っても
なんでそれが苦しんでるんでしょうかとかね
で 幸福になるために この魂にはどうすればいいんでしょうかとかね
で いろいろな問題が出てくるんですね
人生は嫌になってもものすごく怖くなるんですよ
自分が人生嫌なんですけど
もうこういう魂がそういう経験出してくれると
それで死んでも あーいやいや
これがっていうことになっちゃうんですよ
だって魂が自分に不幸を作ってくれる
嫌な気持ちを作ってくれる
その魂が永遠ですよ 永遠だと思っちゃうところで
人がもう人生嫌になっちゃったら自殺しちゃえば簡単なのに
これできんですよ だから死ぬっていうことを思ったところでも怖くなるんですね
はぁ やれやれ これがもう永遠に苦しまなきゃあかんでしょうとかね
だからもう大変ですよ
そういう考え方を作っただけで
それでまた あら 魂は永遠だから人は殺せないはずですよと
という風になっちゃうんです
人は殺せない 殺したっても
ただ体が壊れる 体が魂じゃありません
だから壊れると それで堂々と言うんですね
人を殺しても罪っていうのはありくはない
殺しても別に殺したことにはならない
ならない 殺すことも殺させることもできないと
ということになって こんなこと言っちゃうとまた困るでしょうね
人を一人殺したっても
人一万人殺したっても
罪も何もないんだと で
その同じ考え方から 素晴らしい良いことをしたっても
別に永遠の魂っていうのはそれによって成長するわけないでしょうに
魂は永遠だから 魂が成長しちゃって困るんですよ
どこまで成長するかわからへんでしょうに
だから魂には成長はないんで永遠ですよ
個体です で 魂がある 魂に成長があると言っちゃうと
また矛盾が成り立つんです
なぜかというと そうすると成長していない
すごく小さな もうつまらない魂を持ってる生命やらね
すごく成長した魂を持ってる生命が現れますから
これまた困っちゃうんですよ
それで永遠の実体が成長するんだって言ったら
どこまでですかという風な
このリミットを考えなくちゃあかんでしょうに
これちょっと考えられないんですね
もう考えた馬鹿もいるんですけど
この無限大に広がるんだよとか
なんとかとかね だからこうやって個人に魂があるんだと思った時点から
もう困るわ 困るわ 困るわ
何言ってもどこかで引っかかって矛盾になって困ることになるんですね
しかし 人間っていうのは
そういうとことん自分を不幸にする困る思考っていうのは
何を捨ててもそれだけは捨てません
だから仏教は破壊になってしまったのはそういうわけなんです
そういう思考を捨てたんだから
人々はだったら仏教は要りませんと
我々今まで考えてきた思考は全部捨てちゃったと
そこで今まで仏教を実践した人々にとっては
これはもう困るんで 自分の生き方もうやめることになっちゃうし
それでやっぱり捨てたものをまた導入しましょうと
仏教にも魂という概念は入れちゃったんですね
そうすると元の仏教の人々に怒られて追い出されちゃったんです
そこはもう大乗仏教の出発点なんですね
大乗仏教ではもう実体っていうものははっきりあるんですね
で 大乗仏教の思想を見るたっても
この世間から自分を説明する
例えば法華経なんか読んでみると
必ずこの絶対的な仏様はなんとかとかいて
そこからもういろんな話をする
といって こう多宗派に入ってしまったんです
諸宗派の魂論には入らなかったんです
ということで それからそういうことを見て
私たちは何考えるかというと
やっぱり人間の特色ですね
この人間をものすごく悩んだり苦しませたりする
この思考にこだわること
概念にこだわることは絶対ある
それで「あんた困ってるでしょ」と言っても
それは絶対やめません
やっちゃうんです だから
簡単に言えば「妄想することをやめなさい」と言ったら
その妄想をやめたと思って
そのために妄想する 「
自分は妄想していたんだ
妄想は間違っていたんだ」とかね 「
何で妄想したんですか？」と言って
また妄想始まるんです
やめません それは で そういう結果になるんです
本当に仏教 お釈迦様の教えを知っている人は
もう何一つの概念は持たないんです
しかし 概念何も持たないっていうことは
そう生半可なことじゃないんですよ
何か人間概念持っているんです 「
私は何も概念を持っていない
何も考えていない」ということが
これは生半可なことじゃないんです
偉大なる人物でなければできるものじゃないんです
なぜかというと ただ単純で 「
私はイスラム教はあまり好きじゃないんだけど
キリスト教好きだ」というぐらいのレベルでしょ
私はイスラム教やらキリスト教やら
もういろんな宗教で言っている神は信じていないんだけど
そういう組織的な宗教嫌いですけど
しかし 何が神がいるんだよと
という風に思っているだけのことなんです
だから 何も思わないで生きるということは
もう普通の人間にできることじゃないんです
そうやって生半可な思考で 「
あれは信じません これは信じません」とかね
そうできるものじゃないんです
ものすごい知恵が必要なんです
そこはそんなに難しいことでもないんですから
ちゃんと理性に基づいて物事を考えると
それはもう簡単ですよ
例えば 神がどのように現れるかと
結局はここに自分がいる
他人がいるというところから始まるでしょう
人間が経験でしか考えられませんから
それで自分がいて他人がいて
もうその自分と他人を作ったものは何なのかというと
やっぱり地球にいる 空間の中に
だから空間もあってほしいと
で 作らなきゃ現れないのではないかという
いきなり決めてしまっちゃうんです
それ妄想ですよ 作らなきゃ現れないんだという結論を作った時点で
その結論が成り立つかということは自分の経験で考えればいいのに
それはやってない それこそ失敗
見過ごしちゃったんです
で そこはもう前提で入れていたんです
それから 作るんだったら誰が作るかと
もう米だったら聖さんが作るとかね
で 分かりやすい 人間子供だったらもう人間が作るとすぐ分かりやすい
ではこの元全部作ったのは誰ですかと
初めはっていう風になっちゃうんですね
それは神という風に付いてしまう
そこであくまでも推測でいくんですよ
推測に使った概念作らなきゃ現れないという概念自体はまだ成立してないんです
それが合ってるかどうかわからないんです
いまだに わからないのに
その概念を使って推測してしまうんですね
だから推測っていうのは明らかに推測だから
推測には証拠が必要なんですよ
それで永久的に困る羽目になるんです
そこで世界考えちゃうと
そういうことになっちゃうんですね
で 簡単です だから 神ですと言ったって
あんた知ってるんですかと
論理的に考えると 人間にはこの絶対的な神という概念はどうしても常識な人だったら作れないはずなんですよ
だから神が私を造ってから
私には実存的な考え方が生まれるのであって
生まれる以前のことは
現れる以前のことは知るはずがないんです
全くもう呼吸状態で真空状態でのいた存在しなかったんだからね
作る作られる以前は 作られる以前存在しなかったんだから
知るはずもない 知る余地もない
だから絶対的な神っていうのは人間に想像できるものじゃないんです
それをみんなわかってるんです
そういう精神的にイカれてる連中が風景を作ったんだけど
やっぱり頭がね それなりに妄想が浮くんだから
そこら辺ちょっとまずいなとわかってるんです
そこで見事に私に神が言ったと言っちゃうんです
神が言ったならばもうしょうがないんですね
お前は勝手なかったんですけど
私が作ったんだよと そこで信じてしまう
しかし そちらにもその問題があるんです
神が言ったんだから信じるんだからね
その神が言ってることは本当かないかと調べる方法はないんです
どうせ私は知らないことだから
嘘を言ったらどうしますかね
だからその神が本当のことを言ってるかないかっていうことはわからなくなっちゃうんですね
そこでまた困るんですよ
そこでまたいろいろカラクリ
いろんなことを言う 奇跡やらいろんなこと言ったり
だから神ではないかと
完璧でなきゃこの世界を作れないんではないか
完璧な人は嘘を言うはずがないんだとかね
言いながら情報変わるんだから
神は時と場合によって何でもするんだよと
何をする権利も神にあるんだよとなれば
嘘をつく権利もあるんですね
それから私に神は言ったと言っても
なんであなたに言うんですかね
全て作った神は という疑問も起こるでしょ
なんでものめぐとに頭イカれてる人を選んで神がそれを言うんですかね
ごく一般的な人々に言っちゃえばいいでしょうに
例えば世界をすごい権力を持っている政治家とかね
そういう人に言っちゃえば簡単でしょうに
だからまあ誰に言っても私があんたを造ったよと
なんでその人に言うんですか？という問題が出てくるんですよ
だから選ばれた民族あるんだいという概念を作らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
なのに選ばれてない人間にも言うんですね
また 特にフランスの女の子たちなんかにはね
フランスの映画見てもなんか思考っていうのはなんかすごいとわかるでしょ？なんかいつでも暗くて
で もう まあ人間を描く映画としては立派ですけどね
しかし 変というかね まあ現実性ありながら描けているとか
なんかおかしいとにかく
だから選ばれてない人間にも言ったりすることにもなっちゃうし
どう見たっても なんで神はすべての人間に言わないのかとかね
だからとにかく疑問だらけですよ
何を持ったっても疑問は終わらないんですね
なんで神様に言われた通りにやってるのにうまくいかないのかとかね
なんで神を見事に否定する人々はすごく穏やかで気楽にいるんでしょうかとかね
怯えることは何もなくて
金があっても楽しく生活するし
金がなくても楽しく生活する
で えらい悔しがるんですよ
そういう神を信じている人は
だから殺されちゃいますよ
いつでも 人は神を信じるんだったらすごい怖いんですもん
逃げた方がいいというぐらい
もう人間としても信頼できないんです
まあだからこの だが ではすべての思考を捨てるぞということはいいんだけど
それはものすごい難しい
そういう風にこの この
なんでこの問題が現れているのかという
この原因 を調べなくちゃいけないんですね
だから神がいるんでは
いるんでしょうかというものを調べるのではなくて
なんでそういう概念世の中にあるんですかと
私に本当に魂があるのかということを調べなくてもいいんですよ
なんでそこは魂があると仮定するんですかと
こうやって何か探さなくてはいられない
いられない自分が何者かと
何かの言い訳しなくちゃいられない自分って何なのかと見なくちゃいけないのに
だからそれはすべて言い訳なんですよ
生きる上の不満に対する言い訳なんです
神がいると思ったっても言い訳
いないと思ったっても言い訳
だから考えてほしいのは
なんでそういう不満が自分にあるのかという
それが実際にあるでしょうに
じっとしていられない不満というのは
納得いかない不満というのは
これが明らかに赤ちゃんの時はあった覚えがないでしょうに
忘れているんだからね
あったかもしれませんだけど
だったらもう現実な世界から現れた不満でしょうに
だからそこら辺は研究できるはずなんです
具体的に それでこの 意見捨てるということは
この意見というのは単なる妄想である
根拠はない それは信じると人間には限りない苦しみと不安が生まれていく
幸福になるところがどんどん不幸にもなる
この意見がこういうわけで現れたと
でも何のも裏付けも証拠も根拠もないと
証拠も裏付けも何も根拠もないものであろうとも
信じていればいくらか人間幸せになればマシなんですけど
それもないと ということは
分かった人に限って その意見から心を自由にすることができるんです
この考え方は このこの経典で
アーディンエーヴァヌコーバンテービッコーノマヌシカロートーという一言葉で
もののアーディというものを考えるならば
お釈迦様はそういう意見なんかはひとかけらもなくなくなるでしょうと
というアーディという言葉なんです
オリジンという だからこの
見た目見た簡単じゃないんです
この経典は たった一行で言っているのは
このこのような今説明したような世界なんです
そこでチョンダ長老の頭の中で
世界で人間の中で現れているすべての哲学思考は頭の中にあるんです
すべてまとめて だから２種類にまとめているんです
これのアーディ なんでそんなことになっているのかとわかるんだったら
そんなのはなくなるでしょうと
ということはお釈迦様に言うんです
しかし このアーディという言葉は
あまりお釈迦様は使う使う言葉ではないんです
アーディっていうのはオリジンだから
元の元の原因だからね
元の原因 人間探しちゃったんだから
神がいるんだよとかね
いないんだよとかに そういう風に考えるんだけど
この思考ちょっとおかしいんですよ
だから例えば卵ですかね
先はヒヨコですかねという
先ということを考えちゃうと
もうやりきれなくなっちゃうんです
だからこの初めはアダムとイブが現れたという人々も
卵先ですか ニワトリ何だったっけ？ヒヨコが先ですか？と
考えた思考なんです そこでやりきれないんだから
ではヒヨコにしましょうと
ニワトリいえ やっぱり卵にしましょうという風に
どちらかにしてするんだけど
落ち着かないんですよ
だから作らなきゃ現れないと言った時点で
初めは神がありきということを言えなくなりますから
なんでその人だけ初めから見るんですかと
やっぱり初めは考える人々にも初めがない状態がないと考えられないんですね
初めがない状態がないと考えられなくなっちゃう
だからもう自己矛盾もいいところなんですよ
どんなものにも始めはあるというならば
神にも始めがあるはずなんです
それだったら神を創った神がいるはずなんです
それその人を探すどころか
自分の一番近い神も見つからないし
でも推測するならば 初めから神いるわけじゃないんだから
神を創った人がいるはずなんですね
そうなっちゃうと その神も初めはいるわけないでしょうに
その神も創った神がいるはずなんですよ
だから絶対的な神探しても
これ延々いくんですよ
これ結局はもう鶏か卵かというふうな同じ思考なんですよ
あまりにも単純でだらしないんですよ
しかしどうですかね 世界でそれなのに
そういう単純な思考に基づいてどれぐらい哲学を作ってるんですかね
だから仏教を知っている人には
どんな哲学でもすごくものすごくつまらなくて
なんだこれかというふうに見えるはずなんです
その理性っていうのは
頭に自分が概念を持ってないんです
その代わり理性があるんです
すぐ見えちゃうんですよ
そういうものに羨ましいとかね
やっぱり私も信じるぞとか言って苦しみを作らないんです
だからこのチョンダ長老を使った言葉でも
アーディというね あまりよくないんですよ
それでお釈迦様はチョンダ長老が言ったことはね
間違ってるわけじゃないし
しかしちょっと言語学的にはちょっとやばい
アーディという言葉は
それをお釈迦様は返るんです
ヤーイマチュンダ
アネーカ ヴィター ディッティョー ローケー ウパッジャントリー アッタワーダ パタサンユッター ワーローカワーダ
パタサンユッター ワーヤッタチャエーター ディッティョー ウパッジャッチャ
アヌッセンティ ヤッタチャ サムダーチャランティ
タム ネー タム ママ ネー ソー ハマスミ ナメー ソワッタティ エーワメー タム ヤタハポータン サммаパンニャーヤ パ
ッサトー エーワメー ターサン ディッティナム パハナンホーティ
と言って このすべてのディッティが意見がどのようにすればなくなりますかというなくなる方法をお釈迦様はもっと具体的に説明する
物の始めを考えましょうと言っても
これ単語はやばいんですよ
あと キリスト教の方々はものの初め
考えをしたでしょうし
お釈迦様の時代のバラモン教もものの初めを考えていたんだから
だから絶対的な神というのは偉大なる西洋で生まれた思考じゃなくて
もう随分昔 インドでかなり発展していた思考なんですよ
現代キリスト教 イスラム教よりは哲学的にはものすごく発展しています
ブッダの時代よりも 唯物論というね
そんな霊的なものはないんだと
ただの物質が合成しているだけですよという
この世紀で現れた唯物論なんかは
紀元世紀の時代でもインドではもうじりじりとあったんです
それまたすごい哲学者たちなんです
だからまあ哲学思考の場合
やっぱりインドはなかなかですよ
エジプトとか文明とかね
そんなにすごい思考ってないんですね
ピラミッド作ったりとかね
くだらないことばっかりやってるんだからね
もう太陽を信じるぐらいの話でしたから
そんなどうったことはないんですよ
ただスケールが大胆 自然破壊することは大胆
インド人はそれはやらない
自分の思考に基づいて自然破壊して巨大な何か作ろうとかね
それはないんです まあその差だけなんですけどね
まあですから インドでもものの初めは考えた人々はいたし
その人々はものの初めを考えようとして
変に変な考え方をして
邪見という哲学思考概念を作ってしまったし
でもはっきりと初め考えちゃうと消えそうという言葉っていうのは
ちょっとお釈迦様にとってはこれはちょっとやばいんだから避けた方がいいということで
どういうふうにすればこの哲学思考はなくなりますかと
これがこういうことやと
いかなる思考であろうとも
世界に関わるものであろうか
自我に関わるものであろうか
いかなる思考概念であろうとも
なんでそんな概念が生まれるのかと
概念が生まれるのか 自分のことなんです
自分の気分 なんで私はそんなことを考えているんですかと
なんで考えずにいられないんですかと
この心にあるこのウズウズした状態
なんかくだらんことを考えなきゃいられないという
これ自体自分の不満な状態でしょう
情けない状態でしょ 穏やかでいられない状態でしょ
これがかっこいいと思うんじゃないんですよ
みんなそれがかっこいいと思うんですよ
いろんなことを妄想することやら
気持ち悪いんですけど
世界はこういうものである
こんな調子だったらもうあと二十年で世界は終わりになるぞとかね
あれこれと考える 今はもう地球は全部汚染されているんだぞと
食べ物なんだ だから自分がどこか洞窟でも洞穴でも掘って中に隠れる
そういう人がいるんですよ
もう この世の中ではこんな状態では生きていられませんと
もう罪 もう悪がもう世界をもう支配しているんだと
だから我々だけでも早くも悪に汚染される前に死ななくちゃいかんという自殺したりする
あのグループ自殺 集団自殺
そういういるんですよ
いつでも 時々自分をもうイライラして
もうもうものすごくもうもう何でも壊したくなっちゃう
人を見てももうこいつを殺してやるぞと思ったりして
もうどこか隠れたところで見つけたらすぐ殺しちゃう
また見つからないところで人を見つけたら
もう自分はもうはめられないと思ってまた殺しちゃう
それでどんどん殺していったりして
そこで自分がもうそれなりにそれなりにたくさんの人を殺してるんだから
なんで自分がそんなたくさんの人を
やっぱりこれは自分のこの衝動を治められませんと
どうしても殺さなくちゃいけない
これがやっぱり自分の使命だと
言って このヨーロッパで何人かいたでしょ？あの女の人を殺したりとかね
売春やってる女の人を見つけては殺す
見つけては殺すと あの十七人
十八人か たくさんの人を殺した金持ちの人がイギリスにもいて
それも最近の話で言って
家で全部埋めてるんですね
巨大な大きな家で 子供
ほとんど子供ですね 殺してるのは子供と女の人と
言ってすごい立派な人だから
話しかけたら まあ貴族系の人でしたからね
みんな信頼して それで家に連れて行って
誰でも行ってみたいんですよ
そういう古い豪邸みたいなものに行ったらやられちゃう
で見つかったりするし
このヒッパという そうやってこの通りまでたくさんの人をもう殺す人での一番最初はかなり前なんですけどね
で その人は医者なんですね
これも結構昔の話で ですから
このそういう人々も自分の使命だとか何とかとか思ったりして
だからこの こういう妄想っていうのはかっこいいわけじゃない
あれだから人殺しはでもこれはもう使命だと思ってかっこつけるんですよ
私は特別な使命を受けてる人やと
言って こそっと外を夜出て
誰かを殺して 何も知らんふりをして帰ると
また堂々と昼間はもう立派な社会人で行動する
それで人間というのはいろいろ妄想したりするわ
もう「私は仏だぞ 仏だぞ」とある女がテレビで叫んでたでしょうね
私に向かって「あんた方警察どもたちは何言うんですか」という態度なんです
だからそういうふうなこの妄想が妄想をかっこつけて言うと
もう明らかに精神的にはイカれているということなんです
答えは だから神の言葉が聞こえるんだったら
もう病院に行った方がいいんです
いろいろ神は自分に見えてきて奇跡を見せるんだったら
もう諦めた方がいいんですよ
立派な人間でいるということは
何するかわからなくなっちゃうんです
それで商売に目がない人々
さっとそういう人の中でさっと入り込んじゃって
これでもうもう存分もう自給を始めるんですね
じゃあその時点でこの妄想はもう派手にもう
もうどうにもならん状態にやってる人々にとっては
もう結構居心地はいいんです
俺はすぐ誰か群がってきて
まあそれでまあ その人を神に仕立てて
あの商売やるんですね
最近現れたのは あの なんとか宇宙の電波研究会とか
何でしたっけ あれ え？フェニベーブとかね
だからこのどこでもそれ抜いてすごい激しい宇宙からね
もう人を地球は破壊する
もう電波が届くんだけど
それで自分たちが自分を守るため
そのあの女の人をね 殺すためにワサワサと宇宙からもう波動を送るんですよ
しかし あの白い布かけておけば届かないんです
電波探知機するためにはちゃんとした科学的な機械は作ってます
使ってますが あの白い布は通らない電波なんです
面白いでしょ 携帯電波でもやっぱり白い布なんていうところが壁も通っておりますけど
それが真面目に信じるということは素晴らしいでしょ
人間の思考能力の素晴らしさっていうのは
ある人は私に手紙書いてあって
自分はもうこれ あの手紙は
あの何書いてるかっていうこと読めないんです
で あの 私が書く文章みたいに一行目二行目はぎっしり繋げてるっていうことはないんです
私はやっぱり私の書くのはみんなわからないと言うでしょ
しかし 一行は何が書いて
二行目は何が書くということは私にわからないんです
私のは一行目で書いた論理に従った二行目書いておかないと
でしっかりしません ですから
書いたものの一行は取ってしまうと崩れるんですよ
あの説明文章があったら取ってもいいんですよ
それは説明だからダブってますからね
でないと取れないんです
しかし この一行目で一つ鶏のことを書いて
二行目でこのもみのことを書いて
三行目で隣のピザ屋さんのことを書いたりしちゃうと
私に何言ってるかわからなくなっちゃうんです
何か論理的なつなぎがないと
それでも読んで私は論理的に繋げたんです
で 自分が特別すら人間だ
世界は自分に引き方はしていないんだ
みんな肉 魚食べてるんだ
これは絶対認めません
[咳]自分の舌を 何て言うんだっけ
喜ばせるために人の生命を奪うということは絶対認めない
だから 人間のこの生き方っていうのはどういうことかと
だから私には人間と仲良くすることはできない
しかし この世の中では生きるということはみんなと一緒に生活することでしょうと
だからみんなと一緒に生活することはできない
そういうことを書いて
あんたはどう考えてるんですかと
うん だから まあ見事な理屈ですけどね
パナビューと同じ思考ですけどね
で それで私はまあ私の書き方もありますからね
生半可な書き方しないんです
まあ炎上なしに書くんだからね
私はもうあなたは肉魚食いたくないんだったら食わないでくれと
なんで人に文句言うんですかと
あんた優柔不断やと 性格は情けないんだと
自分が何かやると決めたならば
自分でやることで 人のことをなんで気にするんですかと
あんた言ってること あの人は肉魚食ってるんだから私には菜食主義できないんだよという話でしょうと
それは優柔不断だというんだよと
もっと書きたかったんですけどね
頭イカれてるんだよと
それを書かなかったんです
そこで次のメールがあって
まあそういうところもあるかもしれませんと
言って 自分またぐちゃぐちゃなんですけどね
自分が出家しなくちゃと
出家するかしないかということ
これは私は判断するものであって
自分の意見を貫いて生きるためには
といういろんなことを書いて
また社会との調和のことを書くんですね
で あなたの意見は何なのかと
私にはこのあなたの意見が欲しいんだけど
この何て言いますか ありがたい説法とかそういう思考なんか要りませんと
正直な気持ち だから書きたくて書きたくてたまらんです
正直な気持ちは だから誰に向かって何書くかと思ってるんでしょうかね
その人は 大体仏教的な場合はそれ言ってくださいと言わないと
こちらの品格がないことになるんで
それでも書かなかったんですけどね
で あなたはどうやってこの世界で生活しているんですか？あなたにそんな矛盾がないんですかと
でも自分にはないんだと
または だから自分に矛盾の
この世界で自分の考え方を貫いて生きることには矛盾がなければ
私に聞く必要もないでしょうに
だからカッコつける自分には何の問題
あなたの意見なんか聞きたくもないと
でも意見教えてくださいという
で 日本のお坊さんも何とかこの社会人と一緒に
もうもう妥協して生きていると思いますけど
しかし 霊学者がいないことは誠に残念ですと
で 私はもうあなたの手紙はわからないんだと
何言ってるかと ですから
このフレーズごとに切るんだと
私はあなたの文章をフレーズごとに切って返事書きますと
フレーズ一部に意味があるんだからね
そのフレーズの次の半分に意味がない
これつなげないんですね
だからフレーズごとに切るんだと言って
フレーズ一つ切ってそれに書くと
次のフレーズを切ってそれに書くと
二度とメール来ないと思いますけどね
で 出家としてあなたはどうやってその問題解決するんですかね
私は四十年間の出家をね
一行二行で書けと言っても
それぐらい能力は私にないんだと
四十四年間の経験 経験書くためにはね
二行で そのつもりもありませんと
一つのフレーズにあなたの意見は何なのかというと
これであなたの経験とかね
それはまあ四十年間の自分の経験ね
だからお前みたいにということは読めるようにするんです
でもお前みたいにイカれた人に言うもんかっていうことは感じられるように
これは二行で書けと言っても
そこまでは能力はないんだと
しかし 書いたっても我々の文化が違う
考え方は違う 生まれた環境は違うんだから
もう書いたって役に立たんでしょと
また書いて で 最後にあの出家っていうのは社会生活ですよと
だから私の意見貫いて正直に生きたい人には合わないんだと
だから格好の中でも書いたら
精神病院は一番いいと思いますと書きたかったんですけど
それはもう書けませんだからね
それであなたどこに出家するかっていうことによっても問題がありますと
キリスト教でやるか イスラム教でやるか
日本の各宗派でやるかって
どちらにやったって問題は同じですよと
その宗派の中で社会ですよと
個人の意見は貫くことはできないんだよと
だからふさわしくないんだと
その代わりに あの あなたにまあ私の意見を聞いた
あなたには霊能力に満たしてるでしょ
だから私はどんな気持ちでいるかをいるかと霊視してください
そうすると間接的ではなくて
私の状況は直視できますよと
その代わりにこの出家はふさわしくない
しかし あの自分の意見を貫いて自分なりの生き方を知りたければ
自分で考えた出家システムはどうですかと
もう言葉も作って作って
いわゆる霊学 霊学教とか何とか作ってあげた
作ってあげたかったんですけど
そこまで面倒見る必要ないんだからね
霊学教の開祖様という
ものすごく自分をすごいもう人間をバカにして
それも書いたんですよ
あの社会を認める社会に認められたいという社会人を手玉に取りたいと思っても
これ無理じゃないの？彼がそれ言ってるんですよ
でも自分の妄想はもう正当化
すごいかっこいいと思ってるんだから
この下品なところ見えないだけ
だから妄想は妄想で見ると
いかに下品で精神的に枯れてるかっていうことはわかるでしょうに
だから彼が社会とどうやって付き合えばいいかっていうことを聞くんだから
でも自分の意見を貫きたいんですね
社会をバカにしているでしょ
社会の連中は憎く思っているんだ
私はその連中と一緒には生活したくないんだぞという
しかし仲良くしたいんだと
柔軟性があって穏やかで生きていたい
それは社会を手玉に取る気持ちでしょうに
社会は認めませんけど
社会に認めてほしいという腰抜け思考でしょうに
だから妄想するんだけど
この 性がないんだからやられてるんですよ
自分と社会の違うところで見せた人
違うところ 例えば私は霊の霊能力についてはすごい興味あるって書くんです
それは謙虚で書くんだけど
本当の意味は私には霊能力があるんだって意味なんです
文章に読み方もありますからね
だいたい本人そこまでは言わないんです
私には興味があるっていうところで
そういうことを言いたがっているんです
だから私はそんなに霊能力に満たしているならば
私のことを霊視すればいいんじゃないんですかね
だからこのそれは何でその例を出したんですかというと
やっぱりこの妄想っていうのはかっこいいと思っちゃうと
もうダサいんですよ もう
あまりにも恥ずかしいんですよ
だからそこら辺はね まあだから仏教はいつでもアリーヤの教えです
いわゆるノビリティノーマル
もう高貴な人々の教えだと
この醜い もうみっともない性格っていうのはもう極力避ける
そこはすべて妄想から
思考 概念から現れる ですから
この思考概念捨てるためには
どんな思考であろうとも
世間に関わるものであろうか
自分に関わるものであろうか
その自分がこうではないか
ああではないかと思うでしょうに
そう思わす思わずにいられない自分のこのイライラ状態を見て
これが私でもない 私の魂でもない
私の実体でもないんだと
ただの感情であるとしっかり
ヤタヤタブータン ありのままに如実に見な見なさいよと
そうすると消えてしまう
ただの妄想やという こういうわけで現れたんだと
って言う だからこの阿字ではなくて
お釈迦様は如実に見る
ありのままに見るという言葉に入れ替わるんですね
それで全ての思考概念というのは消えてしまうと
でもあんまりこの経典のポイントは
このそのポイントではないんです
ただ マハージ長老はそういう哲学に対して言ったんだから
お釈迦様はそういう風に返事して
それで終わるんです で
仏教は精神的な問題ある人々の話を相手にしません
しかし インドではすごく真剣に修行して
修行の結果でいろいろ宗教哲学を作った人々もグループがいたんですよ
真面目に 別に頭がおかしいんだから出家したわけじゃなくて
やっぱり私を知りたい
世界を知りたい これでは在家ではできんと思って山に入って
ものすごく真剣に修行する
瞑想する そうするといろんなサマーディ状態やらいろんなものが出てくる
自分に出てきた超自然的なあらゆる現象に基づいてまた妄想するんです
だからそこら辺でお釈迦様は修行は確か立派
欲も離れて欲からも離れて
社会からも離れて 社会の連中を憎く思っているんだから
俺が出家するんだぞというふうなことではなくて
やっぱりみんなと同じことをやっちゃっても
この私は何者かということを知る暇がない
みんな畑仕事に忙しい
子育てに忙しい だから私は何者かというのは知る余地がないでしょうに
だから私一人だけでも全てやめて
家族も捨てて 財産も捨てて
森の中に入って修行するんではないかと
木から落ち落ちてくれる葉っぱでも果物でも食べて
服がなかったら木の枝でも木の皮でも身にまとって
小欲地足で頑張ろうではないかという立派な方々の問題なんです
この経典が扱っているのは
それでも結論はそれでもイカレてるんだと結論にはなりますけど
しかし そういう方々の一部は褒めるべき
真面目 しっかりやっている
インチキではありません
インドの聖者たちは 仙人と言われる人々は
社会的なヒンドゥ教だったらもうみんなインチキでしたから
だからお釈迦様は堂々と言ってるんですよ
あんた方は名前だけやと
しかし ちゃんと出家して修行する人々にはそういうふうには言わない
名前だけやとかってのはみんな真面目でしたからね
そこで世界はその人はちゃんと自分を戒めていると思ってるんです
それでお釈迦様は戒めって何なのかと説明してるんです
ああいう風に超能力を得ても
それは戒めではありませんと
そういうことからも 結局は何か哲学
宗教概念が現れてくると
だから高いレベルに瞑想して禅定を作っても
そこから私は何者かと考えちゃうんです
例えば自分のサマーディ状態で
もういろんな神々がすごく立派にいることが見られる
長い時間 それで人間には瞑想経験があると時間を延ばして考えますよ
タイムカプセルに入ったような感じで
じゃあ 1000年前の状況は何なのか
2000年の前の状況は何なのかとか
過去は見られます タイムカプセルで将来には行けません
あのバックトゥザフューチャーという映画で描いていることは
それはできません 将来には行けませんだけど
タイムの時間の軸で過去には行けます
起きた出来事だから で
それにはタイムマシンはいりませんし
瞑想しなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで瞑想して能力を得た人が
例えば自分の能力で天国やら梵天やら見るとします
見るとはっきりと自分はそれはそのまま直視することだから
心を持っていくことだから
そのその状況に そうすると直視できるんですよ
だから証拠も何も要りません
見ただけで それはその通りにことになるんです
そこでまた妄想しちゃうんですよ
そこで引っかかるんです
あ こちらにすごい梵天がいるんだぞというだけで止まっちゃえばいいのに
この人は自分で この人はいつからいるんでしょうか？と考えちゃうんですね
これが無理な話ですよ
本人に聞いても 聞くことはできるんだけど
本人も知らないんだからね
皆様方も知らないんですよ
この地球上でいつからいるんでしょうかと
これは誰かに言われている
あなたは何年何月何日生まれたんだよと言ってるんだから
その日からいるんだよというだけで
自分では知らないでしょうに
出生登録がなければどうやって言えるんですかね
それがない人々も日本にもいるでしょう
すごいお年の方々は はっきりしないんですよ
生年月日は 登録制度がなかった時は
そこで何か出来事でなんとか推測するだけで
じゃあ おばあちゃまが第1次戦争を覚えているんでしょうかとか
それはちょっと覚えていないんだけど
それからこれは覚えて
あ なるほど 第1次戦争終わってから生まれたではないかとか
そうやって推測するしかないんですよ
もし登録した日にちあれば
その日ということになります
もしその登録の時も日にち違う日にち入れたらどうなるんですかね
出生届は 例えば 12月25生まれたのに
やっぱり尊い日にしなくちゃいけないんだといて 25日にする
十五日生まれたのに 十日間ズレてるでしょ
それは私は自分の経験で知ってるんです
自分 小学校の時はなんかすごい体が私よりもものすごく成長しているんですけど
年聞くと同じ年か ほんのちょっと違うかとかね
何よこれと 私はお前同じ年です
お前 私より随分成長しているのではないかと
いろいろ小さい頃それ調べたところで
どういうことかというと
昔話だから 家出とかいろんなところで生まれるでしょ
届けなくちゃいけないんですね
そういう人々はあまり文字も書けないし
そこで役所に行って 何か名前入れて
父親は母親も名前入れて
生まれて で その日 その日に散るんですよ
そこで一年 二年ズレてる人もいるんです
忘れちゃって 一年も忘れて
やっぱりこれもう誰かに言われて
これは良くないんだよと
学校なんかに入れられなくなるんだよなんとか言ったら
これはやっぱりということで役所に行くんです
行ったら一年前でということは登録できんですよ
一週間か十日と何か日にち決まりあるんだから
だったら今日のしましょうとかね
ということになるんで
だから出社証明書があっても
本当にその日にちで時間で生まれたかっていうとわからないでしょうに
なんでそれ知ったかというと
やっぱりホロスコープ書きますから
それが出生届よりも人間には大事なんですね
だから生まれて時はそこら辺でそういう能力ある人々がどうせ手出す
手伝いしたりするでしょ
何時に生まれた 大体昔は子供が生まれると
このホロスコープ書く人もその家に行くんです
行ってその時間を見て
あ この子はこういうこういう子とその場でそれ基本的なところは書いてくれる
だからホロスコープではもう一応いくらか日にちぐらいは合ってる
時間は合ってないんですけどね
昔の時計で見るんだからね
これまた当てにならない
だから私に聞いて 聞いても
あんたはいつからいるんでしょうかと
知るわけがないでしょうに
天国やらそちら辺ではこういう登録証制度とか何もないんですから
それでその人が相手に聞いても答えが出てこない
当たり前に 梵天に聞いても
そこで自分がその人の過去を見ようではないかと思っても
これは自分の能力あるところで終わっちゃうんです
自分が精神的な瞑想の力で能力をもらってるでしょ
その能力は尽くところで
それ以上は見られないんですよ
だから例えば一億年は遡れると
もしその梵天の寿命は十億年だとする
一億年遡ってみたっても
すごい正々堂々といるんだから
そこで推測するんですよ
私は一億年も遡ってこの人の寿命を見ました
でも一億年先もこの人は正々堂々と同じ姿でいるのではないかと
ということは こいつは永遠だということになるんです
そこら辺は推測ですよ
だから私もこちらで生まれ変わった方がいいんじゃないかなと
空間的に考える 永遠な場所に自分も行ったら永遠であると
それまた仏教は認めませんよ
空間的な思考は みんな堂々と思ってますよ
幸せなところに行ったら自分も幸せやと
豊かなところに行ったら自分も豊かやと
ちょっと甘くないんですかね
その話は 金の皿に入れるもの全部金になるんですかね
それは器は金だったら
そちらに入れるものは何でも金だよと
いうような話ですよ だから永遠なところに行ったら自分も永遠になるんだということは堂々と言っているんです
[咳]だから仏教は梵が一入なんとかあんたしたっても
それは不可能と言わないんですよ
瞑想したら梵天に生まれ変わりますから
あんたね 無常のやつらは無常だよと
全て無常だよと 生きてるあなたに無常だと言うんだから
梵天も生きてるでしょ
だから計算してみなさいと
生きてるということは無常ということやということにするんですね
ただ そういう話にはもう矛盾は成り立たないし
逆らうこともできない
しかし 誰も認めないんです
逆らえないんだけど 認めませんという面白い現象なんです
だから この経典でこのいろんな禅定の話が出てくるのは
そういう真面目な人々は本当に真面目ですかと
これは真面目じゃありませんと
本物の真面目ではないということを言いたくて
この経典は続けています
残りはまたいつか時間があったら説明します
で この本はこのすごくこの大事なテキストです
で 一番大事なところは後ろにありますので
難しいことを話してから
お釈迦様はすごい分かりやすいところで結論出すんです
で 残りは他の次回にしましょう
生きていれば  何かご質問などおありですか
特にないようでしたら少し早いですが
今日の経典解説はこれで終わりたいと思います
早くないです 質問の時間です
あ どうぞ はい 妄想とは違う
ん？ 妄想とは違う 真理
真理の特徴っていう あまり私よく分かってないんですが
うんうん はいはい  妄想とは違う真理の特徴っていうのは
について  うんうん 真理のっていうのは
ありのままの姿っていう意味だから
ただ言葉の遊びだけになりますけど
これは妄想とは関係ないんですね
例えば自分の後ろにあるのは桜の木でしょ
ありのままの事実でしょ
そこは妄想と関係ないんですよ
例えば地球が丸いっていうことは事実でしょ
そのようにどうにもならない
絶対的なんです 真理っていうものは
妄想っていうのは自分で考えたものなんですね
私は空を綺麗だと思うということは妄想なんです
なぜならば 自分がそう思うんだからといって
確かに空は綺麗です これは鏡
事実ですということにはなりませんね
例えば今日は金曜日ですということは事実でしょ
ありのままの話でしょ
もし私は金曜日だと思うんだけどと言っちゃうとちょっと怪しいんじゃないんですか
そう言う場合もありますよ
我々はその時はちょっと日にちが頭の中でずれちゃって
相手もなんか分からない
カレンダー持ってなく
持ってなくて それで二人でしゃべるんですよ
私は金曜日だと思います
あれ金曜日じゃないよ
土曜日じゃないの今日はと二人で話し合う場合は
それは妄想の世界なんですよ
だから私は金曜日だと思っても
相手が土曜日だと思っても
今日は何曜日かということは決まってるんです
真理っていうのはそういうものなんです
私の主観とは関係ないんです
私はそう思っても思わなくてもどうでもいいんです
例えば 私は地球が平らと思っても
四角いと思っても どうでもいいんです
地球は丸いんです だからブッダが真理を語ったという場合は
我々はブッダをブッダが何を語ったかと調べなくちゃいけないんです
本当におっしゃる何をおっしゃったんですかと
そうするとおっしゃったものは真理だそうです
であるならば 私の考え方に関係なく
それはそのままの事実であるはずなんですね
私たちはそれをやろうとしなくちゃいけないんですよ
真理の定義は今の説明で理解すればよろしいと思います
例えば聖書から言えば
聖書で I am the truth という言葉がありますね
私は真理である とイエス様が言うんですね
その場合の真理と 今私が言っている真理の定義が違うんです
それで彼が何考えてるかというと
もう彼が自分が神であると思ってるんですね
勝手に 誰も認めてないんですけどね
だから神は全部作ったならば
それが真理なんですね
神たる自分もだから真理になるんですね
だからそれが I am the truth ということは
別な英語にすると I am the God なんです
だからキリスト教の方々にとっては God が真理なんです
仏教ではそうじゃないんです
妄想と違うものであって
他何もないと だから地球が丸いということは仏教でも真理なんです
しかし 地球は丸かろうがなかろうが
それはキリスト教では真理じゃないんです
神のみが真理なんです
地球が神が作ったものだから
神がそれを壊しちゃいますよと
だから真理ではないんです
だから どんな生命から見ても
生命の主観には全く関係なく
ありのままの姿に真理と言うんです
そういうふうな基本的にわからないところはちゃんと聞いてください
ただね いい加減にいたずらみんな言葉使っちゃいますけど
そういうふうに聞いた方がいいんです
そうするとはっきり意味ははっきりしますからね
一つよろしいですか  はい
俺が新聞見たらイスラムイラクでですね
イスラム教の中でですね
いわゆる動物犬はね 不浄なものであるという記事が出たんですが
これあの 要するにイスラムでは犬が入った部屋でもこれは不浄の部屋
人間にとっては非常にまずいと
そういう考え方があるようなんです
仏教ではそれはどういう一般的に動物に対してどういう考えを持って
仏教ではみんな生命同じということを取ってますから
そうやって差別はしないんですよ
それ罪だと思ってるんですね
不浄ともそんな言えたものじゃないでしょ
体はみんな同じっていうことで
仏教では己の体も不浄であると言ってるんだから
そんな優れたことは言えないんですよ
だから仏教では堂々と私の体はすごく不浄であると
不浄に満たしているんだと
体から離す 離す 離すものは全部汚いんだと
だから不浄の工場やといって
自分の肉体に対しても不浄観するんですよ
だから人間の体が優れて尊いんだと
豚と犬なんかはとんでもない不浄であるとかね
そういうのは仏教から見ればすごい原始的な子供っぽい話なんですよ
例えば心臓を取ってみたら
私の心臓も豚の心臓もカエルの心臓もね
何も変わりはないでしょう
私が死んでも死体でしょうし
犬が死んでも死体でしょうし
だから体がある ある概念で物事を見ているんだから
真理は見えないんですね
真理の目で見るとみんな同じですよ
それから体が不浄というのならば
体が大きければ大きいほど
臓器が大きければたくさんあればあるほど不浄の量が大きく大きいんですよ
だからミミズのほうの場合は
ただもう棒一本だけだから
不浄は少ないんですよ
例えば蝶々なんか死んでも腐らないでしょ
内臓っていうのはほんのわずかですぐ
あの 何て言いますか ドライヤー
何て言いますか 乾燥してしまうんですよ
人間がミイラにならない限りは
もう腐っちゃいますよ
そういうことだから ただ
ごく一般的に仏教は見ているんですね
決して自分より不浄な動物はいるわけじゃないし
自分より美しい優れている清らかな体を持っているものもいるわけじゃないんです
だから そういう人々は
人間の体はすごく清らかだと思っているんですね
でも無茶臭いんですけど
特にイスラム教っていうのは
すごく一日五回顔を洗っちゃう
お祈りする前にね 両足と手と顔を洗ってお祈りする
すごい不浄の概念きついんですよ
それから男でも おしっこしたらちゃんと洗わなくちゃいけないんですよ
しかし さばく水なんかあるわけじゃないんだから
石 小石を取って それから最後の尿の一滴を取って取っちゃうんです
なぜかと聞くと この服に尿一滴付いちゃうと
ものすごい不浄であると
で その思考で犬は不浄だと思っているので
みんなわかってないんです
犬は人間の便食べるんですよ
ものすごい平気で それから豚も同じなんですよ
[笑い]便所はもう荒らしちゃうんです
だからもう不浄に決まってますよ
尿一滴でもあれほど不浄やと思うんだったら
これは堂々と食べる動物のことはもうものすごく恐ろしく怯えちゃうんです
そこは私はこの専門家とずっとそういう話したことありますからね
でもうかなり私をけなしちゃうんで
あんた方は不浄だと 不浄やとかね
あ そうと なんであんたそういうこと言いますかと
そしたら私たちはこれぐらい気をつけるんだよと
体綺麗にするために一日五回
こういうふうに 手はもうここから下は全部洗わなくちゃいけないんだと
足もこういうふうに洗わなくちゃいけないんだと
口もこういうふうに洗わなくちゃいけないんだとかね
そこで結婚した男と女が一緒になったら
すぐ洗わなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから どんなそういうイスラム教の家でも
そうやってこのシャワーは付いてるんです
で そういうのを全て不浄だと見ていて
でも私から見れば体から出すものでしょうに
それ洗っただけできれいになるんですかと
だからそこら辺で論理性は認めません
なぜならばコーランにそう言ってるんだから
あんたの話を聞かない
それでやっちゃうんですね
それであまりにも腹が立って
私は 「あのね あんた人死んだことを見ているんですか？」と 「
見たことあるんですか？」と
で 言ったんです 「人が死ぬ時はね
おしっこも大便も垂らしちゃいますよ」と 「
そうすると あんた方みんな馬鹿見るんだよ」と 「
だって死ぬ時はね もうきったないんだ」と 「
いくら気をつけたって
心臓発作でも起こしちゃうと
もうあんた方は全部終わり地獄や」と 「
みんな だからイスラム教の人は一人も天国に行かないんだぞ」と言ったんです
彼も負けなかったんです 「
いえ それはコーランで認めているんだ」と
それぐらいの教えですよ
そこら辺はね 別に哲学的な内容はないんです
また 他の専門家に聞いたんですよ
なんでそんなに怯えるんですかと
そこはいくらか あ なるほどと思ったんですよ
彼らの恐怖感は 彼らの場合はこの神が天使を委託っていうんですか
雇ってるんですよ 天使たちは二種類なんです
各人に天使がついてるんです
それで二人がついてるんです
一人が全部その人の行いを
良い行いを全部記録する
もう一人は全て悪い行いを記録する
そのお互いに何の共通性もないんです
それで家が不浄だったら
この善行を記録する天使があまりにも汚いところには来ないんです
ちょっとだけでも不浄を見たら
もうそちらにはもう行かないということなんです
それで記録がないんですよ
いろんないいことをしても
天使が寄ってこないんだから
記録に残ってないんです
そこで 汚いところにこの悪いことを記録する天使が来るんです
来て その人に見えるのは悪い行為だけなんです
この天使に見えるのは
それで悪い行為を見る天使は全部片っ端から記録する
例えば この人は一日中十個悪いことをしたとする
しかし もう四百八 八百ぐらい
四千八百ぐらいいいことをしたとする
しかし 悪いことを記録する天使には
その四千八百は見えません
見えたって記録する場所がないんだから
このレジャーというんですか
その本はそうやってできているんだから
例えば悪の記録というところで
この人は貧しい人々を助けましたと言ったっても合わないでしょうに
だから悪の記録の本を持ってくる天使は悪を全部書くんだと
それで審判の時は 各人のこのレコードを持っていくみたい
そのその委任されている天使が
そこで善行を記録する天使は手ぶらで行って
本は真っ白 悪を記録する天使はすごい厚い記録を持っていっちゃうとどうなるかとか
だから彼らがすごく怯えているんです
それ聞いたら なるほど気持ちわかるなと
もうちょっと親切 親切にしなくちゃいけないんだと
結構友達がいたんだから
で 結構私は彼らには邪魔にならないようにと
だって精神的にね 不安を与えてはいけないんだからね
怯えさせてはいけないんだからね
かわいそうですよ 間違ってでも豚とかなんとかとかね
もうかわいそうですよ
人々はものすごく怯えるんです
宗教はどうであろうか
人間でしょ だからそういう精神的な妄想から現れる怯えはね
もうしょうがないんですよ
それで食べる場合は 肉
肉食べる場合でも 自分で殺せないと
殺さないと食べてはいけないんですね
不浄だからなんです 殺してあるものを食べてはいけないんです
どうやって死んだかわからないでしょうし
だから彼らが自分で殺すっていうことをするんです
で 生きたまんまで一発で首を切らなくちゃいけない
首を切って全部まだまだ生きてるんだから
そこで心臓が激しく動いて
全部血液が出ていくんです
だからすんでて血液が出て行ってから人間食べてもいいと
血は一滴でも食べたらもうものすごい不浄で
もうこれだけでその人の運命が定めますよ
もう体が綺麗になっちゃったんだから
天使は逃げる だから並の神経じゃないんです
使っているのは だからいかなる場合でも普通に捌いている肉は食べないんです
それでも現代社会でそんなうまくいけないんだから
昔は聖職者みたいな人々を呼ぶんですよ
いわゆるコーランを覚えてる連中ですけどよ
呼んで その人がすごい鋭い刃物を持ってきて
コーランなんとか唱えてちっと首を切るんです
動物の それ個人個人的に注文して動物殺すっていうことは現代社会で成り立たないんだから
ハラールと言いますけどね
特別にハラールする 例えばオーストラリアで牛を殺す場合は
イスラム教の人がスイッチを入れるんです
言って それをちゃんとイスラム教の人がちゃんと自分のコーランを唱えてやったかということはちゃんと調べて
ハラールというシールを貼っていくんです
そのシール貼ってないものは食べないんです
だから日本ではイスラムの人は日本で売っている牛肉は食べない
食べたら終わり もう全部
道徳は全部無になっちゃうんです
今までの苦労は だから並大抵の恐怖感じゃないんです
しかし そんなに困ることはない
いっぱい売ってます ハラールというものはね
私も外人だからね 結構そういう店も知ってるし
大量に輸入して売っております
だから結構贅沢に食べてます
それで魚はどうしますか？と聞いたら
魚はいいんです 神様が魚を作った時
ハラールしているんだと
我々から言えば便利な説明ではないかという気になるんだけど
それでどうやってあんたがそれ知ってるの？と
見てください 魚はちゃんと切り目が入っているんだと
[笑い]そのキリムは神様が入れたんだと
ということは 貝は食べない
食べられないんです 食べないんです
そこで 例えばこのある日
知ってる二人が イスラム教の・知ってるは知らない
イスラム教だと見たらすぐわかりますからね
三人がマクドナルドで長い時間喋ってたんです
私も まあご飯食べてなかったんだから
そこら辺でいろいろ用事もあって
そこに行って まあ何か食べようかなと思っていて
この人々はコーヒーしか注文しないんです
ポテトチップスも食べないんです
なぜかというと 油が信頼できないんです
聞いたんです 油は信頼できませんと
もし豚の油でも ちょっとでも混ざっていたらどうしますかと
それで友達の家なんかに行ったら
まあ私にも料理作ってくれますよ
まあ何か分からない 私のことを堂々と招待するんですよ
もう来てくださいと あまり行きたくはないんだけど
私が不浄に感じちゃうんですよ
そういう家っていうのは
波動があまり良くないんだからね
まあでも人間だからね
しょうがないし で いい時はもうちゃんと払う
あの  肉は好きじゃって好きってことはないんだからね
まあで 時々ちゃんとちゃんとした料理作りますから
あの もうなんとかぜひ来てくださいとかね
その時も私のことをよく気をつけるという意味なんですね
どうせどうったことはないんですけど
それで肉なんか料理すると
もう洗うというと もう神経ですよ
もう神経質 すっごく洗うんですよ
洗って洗って洗って洗って洗って洗って
いわゆる肉の中でも結石は入っていたらいけないっていうことで
で 料理をする だからそれぐらいの文化的な習慣的なこのストーリーなんです
宗教的なところは天使の話なんです
だから信じる人にとってはもうたまったもんじゃないんですよ
こんなもう天使が来なかったらね
それは仏教はなんでバカにするかというと
神っていうのは来なきゃわからんもんですかと
結局それだけの話なんですよ
いくらなんでもアリスは天使天皇天皇でしょうに
わかるはずでしょうに
なんで天使を委任するんですかと
それで人の家が不浄だったら来られない
善を記録する天使って何なのかと
あれ ジンとかなんとかという名前でいますけどね
まあ天使ですね 日本語では
だからまあ そういうこと
まあ仏教から見ればあまりにもくだらん思考なんですけど
やっぱりそれはその人々に言っちゃえばね
大変失礼でしょうしね
怯えちゃうしね あまりにも怯えるんだから怖いんですよ
動物はなんで人を襲うかというと
すごく怯えるんですよ
怯えたら襲うんです でなきゃ自分で逃げるんですよ
それでイスラム教の人は綺麗かというと
そうでもないんですよ
もう砂漠なんか生活とすごく臭いんだから
この煙を体につけてちょっと臭い消す
あっちこっち香水体を付けてそれで臭い消すとかね
本当にもう もう不潔というともう並大抵じゃないんです
だからお互いに悪口言うのはもうみんな元気でやってますから
私たち仏教徒はもうイスラム人の家には行ってはあかんと
ものすごい不潔やと 思ったりするし
イスラムの人も まあイスラム人は仏教の家には堂々と入りますけどね
向こうはもう全部もう玄関からの鍵をかけて
塀を作って そちらの鍵をかけて生活しているんです
だから住んでるところ行ってみたら
もう本当に不潔ですよ
なのに何でしょうか わからない
ヤギは家の中で飼ってる
ヤギっていうのはどれほど臭いかというと
もう それも健康には良くないし
[背景音楽]豚はない
犬もいない で それにも攻撃したことがあるんですよ
いろんなことに攻撃するんですけど
なんだかとはね もう犬なんかはね
ずっと人間と一緒にいたんだよ
知ってますか？犬っていうのは人間のために命まででも捨てたい気分でいるんだよと
そういう動物をバカにしてね
なんか失礼ではないかと
と と 徹底的に攻めちゃうと
いえ そんなことはありませんと
イスラム教でも犬は飼いますよと
あ そう ったらもう我々はちゃんと外で飼いますよと
飼う場合は 犬のこちらの頭の耳の間
そちらに あの コーランを読む時は犬の頭の上にコーランを乗せて読んでも構いませんと書いてありますよと
と言って 私の反論はもう否定する
そう考えたら あれ何なのかと
まあそれ嘘やと私には言えませんだからね
本人は専門家だから 何なのかと聞いてみると
犬にはこちらは舐められませんね
[笑い]あの人の糞便を食べてるんだから
舌でどこでも舐めちゃうでしょ
しかし 犬には決してこちら上の
あの鼻の上のところ あの
あの 耳の間は舐められません
だからそちらは綺麗です
犬は飼いたがらないのは
犬っていうのはすぐ人の顔を舐めるんだから
それはもうスリランカ人もすごい嫌いですよ
本当は 日本でもちょこちょこと犬をもう舐めたりチューしたりするでしょ
私たちはそれやりません
別に特別な不浄ということではないんですけど
ただまあ嫌いということで
で それも面白いんですよ
例えば私も犬を一匹飼ってますけど
もういつでも抱っこしたりいろんなことはしてますけど
もうやっぱり舐めないんですよ
私 犬もそれしないんです
偉そうに私も偉いぞということで抱っこしてもらってるんですけど
で もうだからといって顔を舐めようということはしないんで
だからやっぱりそれもわかってるかどうか分かりませんだけど
まあやっぱり人間の習慣ですからね
やっぱり動物はそれを真似をしない
あの すいません ある地域でね
今のお話の関連もあるんですが
例えばある国とかある地域で大多数の人が信じてること
例えば常識みたいなこととか
まあ政治に行けばアメリカ人は民主主義が一番だと思ってるし
大多数が それからロシア行けば
中国行けば共産主義が一番
それもやっぱりディッティっていうわけですよね
何？ それもディッティっていうわけですよね
ディッティですよ うん
多数は信じようが少数は信じようが
もう信じるものはディッティですよ
でもそれが今なんか世界を動かしてるから
今だけじゃなくて これはもう今だけのことじゃないです
ずっとこれからもディッティで世界を動かしてますよ
ということは無視はできないってことですか
無視できないんだからそこまで悪口言ってますよ
無視できるんだったら
まあそこを置いといて仏教の話だけでいいでしょうに
人間悟らないのはそういうわけでしょうね
ディッティにしがみついているんだから
心の成長ないでしょうに
もともとも無知だから
理性崩れているんだから
これは仏教の無視できませんよ
私たちにとってはこれが大敵で悪魔なんです
しかし 差別的な思考には持っていかない
これは誰でも あなたも私も誰でも同じやった態度を取るんだだから
まるっきり差別的な方向へ持っていかない
ディッティが少ない人と多い人というふうには言わない
ただ 個別にはディッティにはものすごくしがみすぎて絶対捨てないという頑固でしがみついている人はもう諦めましょうと
そういうことで まあ生きているものはみんなディッティなんです
そこで仏教 お釈迦様はディッティの中でもこの
あの 困った時っていうのは
このディッティに基づいて人間にいいことを言う場合もあるでしょ
そこで困っちゃうんですよ
例えば いかなる生命でも殺してはならないんだと
殺すと自分の魂が汚れるんだよと
いうて汚れる魂はないんだけど
いかなる生命を殺してはならないといって
しっかくそれはそらのこと立派でしょ
ジャイナ教の場合はそういうことでしたから
いかなる生命も殺してはならんと
魂があるんだからとんでもないことやと
自分の魂はどんどん悪くなるんだよという話で
みんなすごい殺生しないことにはものすごい厳しかったんですね
それで そういう人々っていうのは本当に優しくて
信頼できて 人を裏切るということはしないし
だから社会的に見ればすごい立派なんですね
そこら辺はお釈迦様には否定できません
しかし ディッティを壊さなくちゃいけない
そういう場合だけ ちょっと困ったもんだなというところはあるんです
だからジャイナ教と一緒になるで
いつでも仏教はちょっと困ったなというところはいつでも見えるんですよ
その代わりに論理的に
あの ちょっとからかって
まあ崩しますけどね 例えばキリスト教の方々にしたっても
隣人を愛し愛しなくちゃっていうことで
必死になって貧しい人々を助けたりすると
これまでだねとは言えませんだから
その行為自体はいい それもまたディッティに基づいてやることもまた確かですけどね
だからたまたま人の役に立つディッティもありますけど
しかし そちらにも仏教が言うのは
これはやばいと それでも
で 例えばこのメールを送った人は
このなんか人を馬鹿にしてね
仏教では慈悲とかなんとか言うんだけど
私は自分の気持ちは大事にすることは一番大事だと思ってますよと
それは間接的に人のためにもなるのではないかとかね
言って慈悲にケチつけているんですね
私はそれに返事書いてね
まあ慈悲の定義ありがとうございます
しかし 私はあなたの定義ではなくて
ブッダの定義を実践していますと
で あなたに情報提供ために言いますけど
あなたの慈悲の定義とキリスト教の愛の定義はぴったし一致しますと
で メールは長くなるんだからね
引用は省きますということを書いて
あのキリスト教でこういうことやと
あんたは救ってほしければ神を愛しなさいと
神を愛するものは私 イエススを愛するんだと
イエスを愛する者は隣人を愛するんだよと
だから結局己に絡んでるんだよと
あなたの慈悲もそれだ
それだと は言ったんですけど
なるほどね ブッダの教えにまでケチつけると思ってもしょうもないんですけど
で そこでこの  そういうふうにこの神のためにやってるものだから
神に褒めて褒めてもらいたくね
あの マドレ・テレサの話の中ではっきりしてます
マドレ・テレサはなんでああいう風なこの難しい生き方を選んだかというと
この人々のことを心配してではないんです
神のためなんですね だから
やったこと自体は悪いことではないんだけど
ディッティにものすごくしがみついているんだから
その世間が思うほど評価するべきものでもない
それで人々は助かりましたかというと
別に誰も助かったこともないし
最近になって何かこの
子供たちのためにホーム作ったりしているみたいですけど
前はただあの 死にかけている人々をあっちこっちから拾ってきて
あの 死ぬまで まあお粥を飲ませたりとかね
まあそれぐらいのことでしたからね
彼女たちの狙いは死ぬ瞬間ででも洗礼を受けさせて
あのキリスト教にしてやるぞと
なぜかというと この首クラスによって自分の位が上がるんですよ
神にすってあげた首クラスで計算しますよ
この あの 形跡は 形跡 何て言いますか
人の 何歴？ 業績  え？ 業績
ん？ 業績  業績 だから仙人にまで上がったんです
あ 副師匠になったんですか
うん だからそこら辺はちょっと
では 問題ですけども ただ「人間ではないか
見ていられないんだぞ」と言ったなら
すごいかっこいいんですけどね
だからあの ディッティ邪教にいろいろありますけど
まあ恐ろしいものもあって
まあそれなりの人の助けになるものもありますけど
だからディッティ自体はやっぱり怖いんですよ
だからキリスト教とイスラム教の中では
もう明確に た-他人を他殺するというものはもう明確にあるのはそういうわけなんです
ではまあ そこら辺ですみません
どうもありがとうございます